[Music]
to say all hell had broken loose would
be a vast understatement a more
realistic assessment of what had
happened in the aftermath of scp-001 the
lock being opened would be every hell
had broken loose along with every heaven
every anomaly every ancient god and
buried horror every nightmare from outer
space and from different dimensions
every agent of the apocalypse every
emissary of ragnarok every entity
sentient and otherwise with a vested
interest in seeing the world as we know
it come to an end so it goes without
saying the scp foundation and their
allies had their work cut out for them
so before we march once again into the
terrifying future let's quickly refresh
our memories as to how we got here the
lock had started off as a mere curio in
a 19th century explorer's vast
collection before it fell into the
possession of the scp foundation and
became designated as scp-001
for years the lock perplexed people with
its seemingly limitless mysteries from
its origins to its strange markings to
what would happen when the lock is
finally opened and it would indeed be
opened in perhaps the ultimate example
of be careful what you wish for an
entity known as the harvinger invaded
site 10 and used a special key to
finally open the lock triggering the
ultimate apocalypse anomalies became
more powerful and escape containment all
over the world animals mutated into
giant monsters and began causing chaos
mythological creatures such as the
goddess of scp-1000
the mighty norse fenrir and an entity
that transformed into a giant evil duck
went totally berserk the lock itself
completely blew up site 10 before
remaking it and its personnel elsewhere
and turned the crater where site 10 used
to be into an incredible otherworldly
valley on earth where an even more
incredible meeting would soon take place
scp-990 the dream man came to the
administrator of the scp foundation and
warned her of impending doom but she
decided that no matter how dire things
got the foundation would fight back and
that brings us to the star of the show
scp-343 also known as god but please
call him yahweh no point in sticking to
formality here at the end of it all
right ever since the lock was opened by
that pesky mysterious harbinger he'd
been an extremely busy deity last time
we saw him make his long-awaited
rendezvous with another scp-001
the gate guardian whose true name was
revealed to be yurio yahweh instructed
yuril to open the gate to paradise
releasing his armies of powerful
sword-wielding angels upon the earth and
now we're all caught up let the madness
commence after instructing yoriel to
free his armies and lead them in a war
against evil yahweh decided to address
the most powerful humans on earth and
enlist them in his fight those same
arrogant humans who foolishly believed
they'd been containing him all this time
and not that he'd simply been choosing
to stay with them perhaps now they would
see sense yahweh manifested physically
in 13 different places at once and spoke
to the o5 council they were filled with
awe and holy terror as the deity
appeared before them like a glittering
ghost eyes glowing exuding pure power
speaking with absolute authority he said
uriel my servant once told your founder
to prepare for the great and terrible
day of the lord this day now approaches
make your final preparations there is
nothing else you will need to do but
wait my armies ride across the earth
soon i will call the four horsemen once
the last judgment has been unsealed
then shall the great and terrible day of
the lord come
and then
all will have paradise
and with that he was gone leaving the
most powerful human beings on earth
shaken it was about time they got a
reality check about their true cosmic
insignificance still the act of
splitting himself 13 waves briefly gave
yahweh symptoms similar to vertigo
during his confinement he hadn't needed
to truly flex his power and now he was
finally beginning to feel the
limitations of this human form but he
didn't have time to muse over the nature
of human frailty as the world he worked
so hard on began to crumble around him
he needed to return to the valley the
precursor to eden's return the valley
where only he had set foot he breathed a
sigh and teleported there prepared to
finally be alone and collect his
thoughts but he wasn't alone you've
probably heard salicious stories about
parties getting out of hand it always
goes the same way a birthday party or
small gathering created as an event on
facebook but accidentally set to public
not long after little andrea's
quintinera or joe's bar mitzvah suddenly
has 5 000 attendees all strangers and
the riot police are called in to get the
chaos under control now imagine that
same thing but instead of rowdy
drunkards it's cosmic figures and
apocalyptic beings from all over the
multiverse and now you know what yahweh
walked in on
welcome to the valley of gods and
monsters it was crowded with beings that
would boggle your mind to even
comprehend deities with two limbs six
limbs a hundred limbs or none spirit
whales and feathered snakes flew
overhead with clouds of intelligent
insects and fey flying just below a
giant furred creature moved over a
distant mountain looking on a pure black
humanoid entity appeared before yahweh
blinked and then vanished moments later
a giant centipede-like creature
skittered past him giving him a nasty
glare everyone was here the pantheon of
greek gods from zeus to hades every
egyptian god and monster the bird-headed
ra the jackal-headed anubis the
monstrous snake beast apep the norse
gods were drinking and having rowdy
conversations with the hindu deities
entities so ancient their names have
been forgotten and monsters whose faces
had only ever been seen in the restless
dreams of billions of humans then
quickly forgotten upon waking in short
the gangs all hear yahweh for the first
time ever was feeling lost confused and
even small he decided to mingle with the
crowd of humanoid gods wanting to be
with people who looked like him there he
met a dark-skinned woman with long hair
and lip piercings known as asherah
although his memory of her was faint she
reminded him that she was once his
consort back before he made the
admittedly jerk move of wiping out all
the other pantheons of history so that
he could rule over the cosmos alone but
now with the opening of the lock
everyone was back ready to cause the
apocalypse but here was the problem they
didn't just want to cause the apocalypse
they wanted to cause
their apocalypse every belief system had
its own vision for how this strange
little show we called earth should end
and not all of them were compatible so a
very heated debate was breaking out as
to who should really get to bring the
world to an end and the most darkly
funny part of this very few of these
gods entities and creatures even knew
about each other until a few moments
before so the fact that they had this
level of competition was a very
unpleasant surprise to put it in
perspective imagine you're neil
armstrong circa 1969 taking the apollo
11 shuttle straight to the moon the
craft lands he suited up preparing for
the first ever moonwalk his iconic quote
this is one small step for man one giant
leap for mankind already looping in his
head then when he steps off the craft
there are already several people on the
lunar surface lounging on deck chairs
and asking him if he'd like a beer when
he asked them what the hell is going on
they tell him they just got here an hour
ago and were making themselves
comfortable yahweh was beginning to
realize that perhaps he really didn't
hold the sway he thought he did any
bible fans in our audience will know
that the plan for the christian
apocalypse is laid out pretty clear in
the book of revelations satan armies of
angels giant scorpion locusts and in the
end the rebirth of paradise on earth
yahweh thought all things considered his
version of the end of everything
actually shook out pretty well for
everybody a little temporary hell on
earth and painful damnation aside but
here he wasn't the holiest of holies he
was just one guy with a big picture idea
alongside so many other beings each with
their own big picture designs for ending
things all except ashira she'd spent
time in a mortal form on earth and had
really grown to like the place in that
time so much so that she didn't want to
see it end in any manner in her own
words to a baffled and somewhat offended
yahweh i may have been called here but
not even that lock can make me end the
world have you ever tried the seafood in
singapore have you ever used a
smartphone ran through the jungle seen
cirque du soleil flown on an airplane
surfed the internet watched tentacle
porn seen star wars explored the
wanderers library been lost in the
concrete mazes of the new human cities
now i like the world the way it is
thinks it may be messed up but tearing
it apart isn't going to improve anything
so no i don't plan to end the world i
actually don't plan to let you end the
world either or anyone else sorry yahweh
was somewhere between enraged and amazed
his former consort was not only willing
to go against him but every cosmic being
here she was staring down the barrel of
quite literally infinite power and yet
she still stood in defiance of them
yahweh was about to retort when
something even more bizarre happened in
the valley of gods and monsters a
woman's voice rang out simply saying
pardon me in a calm even tone that
somehow caught the attention of every
deity and world ender in the valley they
turned in amazement to see a human woman
in a gray suit standing among them a
face that somehow all these supposedly
all-knowing beings couldn't seem to
recognize but if you as cp explained
fans have been perceptive in the
previous videos it's a face you'll know
all too well the administrator never
shifting her tone or raising her voice
she said i come on behalf of the scp
foundation some of you know who we are
some of you do not the foundation are
the protectors of humanity some of you
we have imprisoned some of you we have
bargained with all in defense of
humanity i've come to talk some of the
entities laughed others sneered was this
woman really arrogant enough to believe
that humans had a seat at this table
no their place was resting on the plates
subject to the mercy of teeth and
silverware not conversation they asked
what she wanted more out of morbid
curiosity than any real desire to know
she replied we can open the way to
worlds free of sentient life many worlds
enough room for all of you you won't
have to end this world no humans will
have to die you will have a hundred
others i want you to let this world live
out the rest of its history and peace
and in return for this we will not
destroy you some laughed others chided
most just remained in silence when none
accepted the administrator's offer she
simply shrugged and calmly delivered
what seemed less like a threat and more
like an ironclad promise to the valley
of gods and monsters we are the
foundation we will not worship you we
will not join you we will not go back to
hiding in fear of you i hope you will
change your minds but we will stand
against you and alone if we have to all
of you and for a fleeting moment before
the administrator vanished yahweh
thought of himself as scp-343
then she was gone at that moment the war
for the fate of planet earth had truly
begun now go check out children of
scp-001 the scarlet king is
scp-999 really his son and scp-001
or borocycle the full story compilation
for more of the universe shattering
implications of scp-001